[Musik]
Millionen Menschen wissen nicht wie sie
Lebensmittel und Energie bezahlen sollen
zugleich versuchen Milliardäre
gigantische Vermögenszuwächse das zeigt
jetzt eine neue Studie von Oxfam ich
freue mich auf diese Gäste heute Abend
hier bei 8:15 Uhr der frühere
verkehrsminister Peter Ramsauer fordert
stoppt die Steuer Schikane gerade bei
der grundsteuererklärung blickt doch
keiner mehr durch wir dürfen nicht die
Augen vor Problemen verschließen sagt
auch Bestsellerautorin Katja Schneid und
meint damit eine neue flüchtlingskrise
Deutschland müssen sich seiner
Kapazitätsgrenzen bewusst werden
vorziehen eine Grenze erreicht ist für
Dr Susanne Schröter beim Thema walkness
die Ethnologin und hochschulprovisorin
waren vor Denkverboten und sorgt sich um
die Demokratie Sebastian Chef der
Berliner FDP sieht unseren Rechtsstaat
im dauerfeuerzeug die Silvester nach
Reichsbürger Verschwörungen er fordert
daher eine bessere Ausstattung von
Justiz und Sicherheitsbehörden und ich
habe gerade eben schon gesagt der
Abstand zwischen Superreichen und
dieselbevölkerung ist so groß wie nie
das sagt der Bericht der
Entwicklungsorganisation Oxfam in
Deutschland flossen demnach 81% des
Vermögenszuwachses der zwischen 20 und
2021 erwirtschaftet wurde an das
reichste Prozent der Bevölkerung und
gleichzeitig sind diese Zahl der
Sparkassenverband schätzt dass bald 60%
der deutschen Haushalte ihr monatliches
Einkommen komplett für die
Lebenserhaltung einsetzen müssen sprich
alles ist weg nichts bleibt übrig Arm
trotz Arbeit und das in einem der
reichsten Länder der Welt wie kann das
eigentlich sein Ramsauer haben sie eine
Antwort darauf
viele Antworten habe ich da drauf das
hat aber in dem Thema
grundsteuererklärung nichts
drauf nur so viel
das hat natürlich mit Statistik zu tun
und die Absurdität dieser
oxfam-argumentation die sieht man schon
daran wenn sie für alle das Vermögen
verdoppeln oder wenn Sie für alle das
Einkommen verdoppeln
nimmt statistisch die Armut zu
also völlig verrückt ist ja ganz klar
das ist Effekt und so weiter und wer
oxfarm kennt das ist ja eine ganz
spezielle Organisation in
Anführungszeichen ich hatte mit denen
einiges zu tun ich nehme das ganze nicht
ernst
zwischen Arm und Reich viele Menschen
die jetzt kämpfen die sich fragen wie
zahle ich meine Lebensmittel wie zahle
ich meine Energiekosten während andere
auch firmenkonzerne profitieren selbst
in der Krise selbst in der Pandemie
selbst durch die Inflation es besorgt
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger das ist
vollkommen klar aber da würde ich eher
jemand aus der ampelregierung Fragen und
nicht einen Vertreter der Opposition
obwohl wir das natürlich aufgreifen
jetzt wenn ich einmal argumentiere
Aussicht der Ampel Parteien dann konnte
man sagen dass die Ampel wenigstens
versucht diese Dinge aufzugreifen also
mit ausgleichen bei den Energiepreisen
mit in die gaspreisbremse
strompreisbremse die ganzen
übergangshilfen die wir schon in der
Pandemie hatten und die jetzt auch
übrigens nicht nur für die Privatleute
greifen sollen sondern auch für Betriebe
Handwerksbetriebe dass die über die
Runden kommen also der Wille zur Hilfe
ist in der Ampel schon da und wir werden
als Opposition das natürlich sehr
kritisch begleiten das ist fast schon
ein Lob für ihre Partei die in der
Regierung hier sitzt Herrscher dennoch
bei 60 Prozent bleibt nichts mehr übrig
die können nicht sparen für einen Urlaub
für ein Häuschen für irgendwelche Ziele
wie sehr besorgt sie solche Zahlen
ja wir haben ganz so weg diskutieren wie
Herr Ramsauer würde ich es nicht und
sagen das ist nur Statistik er hat ja
trotzdem den Punkt gemacht mit dem Blick
darauf dass wir dahin schauen müssen wir
sind in einer Zeit von multiplen Krisen
es werden immer mehr Herausforderungen
erst der der Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine dann die Fragen die sich daraus
ableitende Inflation dann immer noch die
Schmerzen der corona-pandemie all das
führt zusammen zu einem schwierigen
Lagebild und deshalb müssen wir jetzt
hinschauen dass wir kurz und
mittelfristig entlasten dazu haben wir
entlastungspakete gemacht die Ampel
wurde gerade angesprochen wir müssen
aber auch gucken dass wir die Mitte in
unserem Land stärken und tatsächlich für
den Mittelstand in unserem Land
strukturelle auch Entlastung und
langfristige Fragen auch der
Steuerpolitik angehen damit wir dieses
Land weiter stabilisieren und ähm aus
dieser Krise im Idealfall sogar besser
hervorgehen als wir vorher reingegangen
sind sie gehören beispielsweise zur
Mitte glaube ich kann man so sagen ist
das für Sie alles nur Statistik sind das
nur Zahlen die sich noch gar nicht so
richtig spürbar machen doch natürlich
macht sich das spürbar also es macht
sich schon spürbar wenn Sie einkaufen
gehen und sie haben Produkte für die
Zahlen sie mittlerweile das Doppelte und
noch mehr und
ich würde jetzt sagen mir gehören auch
zu den Leuten die uns relativ gut geht
ja aber ich habe in meinem Umfeld Leute
die jetzt wirklich z.B das ist
tatsächlich so die Heizung ausgestellt
haben die einfach gesagt haben wir
können uns die Heizung im Moment nicht
leisten ja oder die plötzlich abends im
Dunkeln sitzen weil sie einfach sagen
unser Stromanbieter hat die Strompreise
so dermaßen erhöht wir können das nicht
bezahlen ja und das trifft vor allen
Dingen Rentner und wissen Sie ich war
über zehn Jahre auch Arbeitsvermittlerin
Unternehmensberaterin und ich frage mich
immer wer denkt sich den Mindestlohn aus
das ist so weit weg von der Realität und
da du kannst damit nicht existieren ja
und ähm ich die Kluft zwischen Arm und
Reich wird ja immer größer das ist ja
bekannt und wir haben den höchsten Stand
der Kinderarmut Zeit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg auch diese Zahlen sind nicht
weg zu diskutieren und ich frage mich
immer warum ist das so warum also auch
diese Hilfspakete die die Politik jetzt
eben anbietet die sind ja nötig weil die
Politik eben in die falsche Richtung
geht und das ist so ein bisschen als
wenn ich ausholen ihnen Ohrfeige
verpasse und gebe ihnen hinterher ein
Eisbeutel damit es nicht so weh tut und
das ist das was die Politik im Moment
macht sie macht eine Politik die
notwendig macht das Hilfspakete auf dem
Weg geschickt werden und das ist an der
Sache vorbei und das hilft auch den
Leuten nicht das ist ein Tropfen auf dem
heißen
Sternzeichen
von außen oder muss man sich da auch in
die Verantwortung nehmen die Ohrfeige
die man auch selbst verteilt hat also
ähm jetzt könnte ich es mir einfach
machen schlanken Fuß und sagen das muss
heran sauer beantworten mit 16 Jahre
Angela Merkel und der Frage was ist
strukturell richtig und was es
vielleicht auch strukturell falsch
gelaufen an diesen Stellen aber auch das
wäre zu kurz gesprungen weil die Sorgen
sind ja jetzt da sie haben es ja gerade
gesagt man sieht das ja wenn man
einkaufen geht man erlebt das ja im
Alltag man sieht das bei der
Stromrechnung wir haben das gerade hier
in Berlin dass der Staat
inflationsgewinner ist hier im Land
Berlin wird während die Netzentgelte 35%
Kostensteigerung die der Staat sich in
die Tasche steckt ich finde das darf
nicht passieren dass der Staat sich als
Krisengewinner sieht sondern da wo der
Staat in der Verantwortung ist wo man
immer gesagt hat wer rekommunalisieren
weil es für dich als Verbraucher am Ende
besser ist sollte jetzt auch für den
Verbraucher sich das Auszahlen und hier
zahlt sich gerade nicht aus wenn man z.B
auch bei den 7% Steigerung bleiben bei
der BSR und den Müllgebühren in der
Stadt Berlin also ich kann den Alltag
einmal durchlaufen wo der Staat
entlasten könnte damit tatsächlich dort
wo wir nicht dran kommen Geld vorhanden
ist um das
noch leisten zu können also man kann was
tun an Vorschlägen und Ideen mangels
nicht wir müssen politisch machen
deswegen will ich nicht wegdiskutieren
und dennoch gehört auch zur Wahrheit
dazu dass die Frage des Angriffskrieges
auf die Ukraine natürlich etwas ist was
für alle hier politisch nicht
vorhersehbar war und wo drauf man mit
den entsprechenden Maßnahmen und
Hilfspaketen ich glaube da sind wir
einer Meinung absolut reagieren muss
die Problematiken gibt es ja schon viel
länger also wenn ich mal überlege dass
wir schon seit Jahrzehnten ein ganz
massiven Wohnungsmangel in Deutschland
haben aber das auch schon seit
Jahrzehnten kaum noch soziale
Wohnungsbau betrieben wird während wir
aber Millionen Menschen die auf
Sozialwohnungen angewiesen sind ins Land
holen aber die Leute die die
ursprungsbevölkerung schon kein
bezahlbaren Wohnraum hat Familie mit
drei und vier Kinder auf 50
Quadratmetern Leben und das ist keine
Ausnahme dann frage ich mich schon aber
wo ist doch ein einfaches Mittel woran
liegt es denn wir haben und zwar ein
Zuzug an Menschen aber wir haben keinen
sozialen Wohnungsbau
überhaupt keinen Wohnungsbau der
ausreichend würde die steigende
Bevölkerung aufzunehmen daran man muss
mehr Wohnungen die Wirtschaft muss mehr
Brummen auch im mittelständischen
Bereich nicht nur die Großkonzerne wir
haben aber eine Abwanderung von
Wirtschaftsunternehmen auch im
mittelständischen Bereich wir haben
Energiekosten die wahnsinnig hoch sind
die natürlich zum Teil zu der Misere
beitragen wenn ich sogar verantwortlich
sind und wenn ich mir aber die
Energiepolitik anschaue das Herumgeeiere
um die Kernkraft dann muss ich sagen wir
wollen hier Elektromobilität schaffen
wir wollen den Stromverbrauch steigern
aber wir haben eigentlich keine echte
Antwort wo der Strom denn herkommen soll
ich meine das geht nicht und das
letztendlich Baden dass die Bürger aus
und das badet der Mittelstand aus mehr
noch als die unteren Schichten weil die
hilft Rakete und die ganzen Markt für
die unteren Schichten sind nicht für den
Mittelstand der Mittelstand ist glaube
ich die Gruppe die am meisten darunter
leidet weil sie gewohnt ist alles
alleine aus eigener Verantwortung zu
wuppen und jetzt merkt das funktioniert
nicht mehr und da muss ich sagen
da braucht man auch keine Hilfspakete
die Leute wollen ja nicht abhängig sein
die wollen von ihrer Hände Arbeit leben
und das muss man ihn ermöglichen
Steuerpolitik da gebe ich ihnen ganz
recht die Abgaben sind wahnsinnig hoch
gerade für Menschen die arbeiten und die
hohe Kosten haben die die
Kindergartengebühren zahlen die auch
sonst alles bezahlen deshalb
Steuereinnahmen die Menschen eine
Million
andert statt finanzieren die müssten das
auch tun können und das muss der Staat
in ermöglicht nicht mit allen Mosen
sondern
Bedingungen also doch nicht nur
Statistik doch nicht nur Zahlen haben
soll jetzt kriegen wir eine
Lebenswirklichkeit von vielen Menschen
mit der Mittelstand der sich im Stich
gelassen fühlt der der
sich allein gelassen fühlt sie hatten
gerade Lob für die Ampel sehen Sie das
jetzt immer noch so sie machen ein Lob
daraus aber man muss
man muss das sage ich jetzt mal noch
über 32 Jahren bundestagserfahrung und
Bundeskabinett und so
20 dezember 1990 also ich bin nächstes
Jahr um 20 April auf dem Tag genau ein
Drittel jahrhundert im Bundestag das
andere da können sie mich einladen dann
um 20 Uhr
[Gelächter]
noch 50 Jahre Wolfgang Schäuble Moment
Liebe Büro Nachbar aber zurück zu ihrer
zu Ihrer Frage
Wirklichkeit er ist gehört einfach zur
Ferne ist dass man gute Ansätze in
Markierung auch mal benennt aus der
Opposition heraus und ich weiß ja wohl
lieber Kollege Czaja wie schwierig dass
das für jede der ampelpartei ist das
alle drei im Grunde genommen das
Gegenteil von dem tun müssen wofür sie
eigentlich bei der letzten Wahl standen
aber lebenswirkungen
aber die Frage war Lebenswirklichkeit in
meiner Zeit als bundesverkehrsministerin
als bundesbahnminister sind wir all
diese Dinge natürlich jeden Tag auf den
Schreibtisch gekommen ich habe mir auch
zum Ziel gesetzt jährlich 400.000
Wohnungen neu zu bauen
im sozial geförderten Wohnungsbau
Zweibrücken im Freien Wohnungsbau
Eigenheim bis große mietwohnungs- und so
weiter und dann bist du täglich und
wöchentlich konfrontiert mit unzähligen
Hindernissen die dir kreuz und quer
reingehauen werden sozialer Wohnungsbau
ist sehr stark auch länderbezogen was
die Bundesländer machen müssen und dann
bekommt man von denen Antworten ja
genommen wird denn dahin das haben wir
noch nie anders gemacht wenn wir das
jetzt ändern würden das tun wir nicht
und da wirst du halb verrückt immerhin
im Zimmer von 190.000 damals 2009 auf
knapp 300.000 gekommen aber die Kollegin
geibels die beneide ich nicht die hat
sich auch 400.000
Bürokratie zu schwierig das können wir
noch nicht gehen
wir machen nicht mit in der Koalition
vielleicht und das kann aber auch dazu
führen herrschaya dass am Ende
Bürgerinnen und Bürger da sitzen und
sagen irgendwie kümmert sich hier jemand
wir sind unzufrieden hören uns was
Ramsauer beschrieben hat als Problem
haben wir jetzt übernommen erkannt und
deswegen gibt's ja ein
planungsbeschleunigungsprogramm und für
uns nächste Woche für uns geht jetzt ich
gebe Ihnen auch konkretes Beispiel für
uns gilt jetzt wirklich das Beispiel vom
lng-terminal als ein Musterbeispiel
dafür in Deutschland wie es gehen kann
und jetzt stellen Sie sich mal vor für
dieses Land geht zukünftig LNG
Geschwindigkeit statt Berge geschrieben
hat dann kommen wir doch an die großen
Fragen an die wir dringend brauchen in
der in der planungsbeschleunigung aber
auch in der Frage der Realisierung und
sie haben vorhin das Thema Wohnungsnot
angesprochen dass hier in der Stadt in
der Stadt Berlin allein hier fehlen weit
über 200.000 Wohnungen die gebaut werden
müssen und trotzdem erlaubt sich diese
statt einer Debatte über die Frage des
Eigentümers Wechsels im Sinne einer
Enteignung statt das Geld nämlich die
Milliarden die dafür notwendig werden in
geförderten oder hier in im Preis
gebundenen in miet gebundenen
Wohnungsbau zu stecken die Debatte
führen wir gar nicht stattdessen führen
wir eine ideologische Debatte und die
Leittragende sind wir Mieterinnen und
Mieter an der Stelle die in dieser Stadt
eine Wohnung suchen und das ist auch
Aufgabe der Politik sich an der Stelle
gerade zu machen und mit den
Herausforderungen richtig umzugehen
statt ideologisch Politik zu machen und
für 40 € beispielsweise um das auch noch
mal weiter in die Realität noch zu holen
das ganze Thema kriegen ihren
Einkaufswagen gar nicht mehr voll selbst
wenn man zum Discounter geht daher auch
mal die Frage hier die beiden Politiker
waren sie zum letzten Mal einkaufen und
was ist Ihnen da aufgefallen im
vorletztes Wochenende mit meiner Frau
das ist für mich immer das
hochinteressante Erfahrung wenn man am
Samstag Vormittag in der
Hauptstadt meines Wahlkreises Traunstein
mitten im Chiemgau
Urlaubsgebiet wenn man dann so schaut
was kosten die einzelnen Sachen wie sind
die teurer geworden eine Butter wie
teuer die geworden ist
ob sie zu Aldi gehen oder oder zu Rewe
und dann die ob sie eine Eigenmarke
kaufen oder Marken oder Markenbutter aus
Bergbauer Milch von der Pidinger
Molkerei oder so weiter da liegen ja da
gehen die Preise um 100 oder 150%
auseinander
kaufen Sie dann die bergbauernbutter
kaufen
in berlin wenn er in Berlin
Joghurt aus Bergbauernmilch angeboten
wird von der großen
genossenschaftsmalerei in Piding z.B ja
da bin ich gern bereit für so ein
Joghurt 1,20 € oder 1 € 40 zu bezahlen
oder wunderbarer Käse von Berga oder
Käse in Waging das sind die beiden
großen Molkerei in meinem Wahlkreis da
bin ich gerne bereit für ein Kilo Käse
oder
kauft mir nicht gleich und entsprechend
weniger und das Geld hinzulegen
gerade viele bereit ich glaube dieses
Thema ist nur das viele Menschen sich
vermutlich diese Frage gar nicht mehr
stellen können ob sie bereit sind für
diese Mehrqualität das zu zahlen weil
sie sagen Eier sind beispielsweise 39%
teurer geworden
dass man wo man überhaupt die beste
Qualität kriegt dann muss man die Kinder
satt kriegen und vielleicht auch mit
einer weniger guten Qualität und ähm es
sind ja die Preise auch angestiegen dort
wo die Qualität nicht so hoch ist ich
habe neulich hier in ber im Flughafen
eine Brezel gekauft für 3,50 € da habe
ich gesagt ich fahre vom Glauben ab
welche Qualität ist in dieser Brezel
drin 50 wert sein soll also ich hatte
das Erlebnis ich habe schon lange keinen
Hund mehr oder was heißt jetzt etwas
über ein Jahr meine Tochter hat mich
gebeten Mama bringt noch mal zwei Dosen
von dem günstigen Hundefutter mit und
dann stand ich voller Verzweiflung im
Geschäft und hat dieses günstige
Hundefutter gesucht was ich auch ab und
zu gekauft habe festgestellt das gibt's
noch das gibt schon noch aber das kostet
halt keine 75 Cent mehr die Dose sondern
die kostet jetzt 1,65 € dieselbe Dose
übrigens Politiker das mit ganz so oft
wird Politikern vorgeworfen haben die
Bodenhaftung verloren die wissen gar
nicht wie unser Leben aussieht jetzt
haben wir hier ein paar Beispiele gehört
kriegen Politiker das mit ja ich habe
selber Ausbildung Handwerk gemacht bin
gelernter Elektroinstallateur meine
Mutter ist Krankenschwester und mein
Vater Elektromeister gewesen ich kriege
das wohl mit ich war gestern früh um
5:30 Uhr auf dem Fruchthof vom
beusselmarkt hier in Berlin wo die
Händlerinnen und Händler genau
beschreiben was da passiert wenn der
Staat die Miete abgreift an der Stelle
20 % mietigung dann heißt es für jedes
einzelne obstteil was da am Markt
gehandelt wird für jeden einzelnen
kita-betreiber Gastronomen für jede
klinische Einrichtung die da ihr Obst
bezieht das ist zu diesen
Preissteigerung kommt weil natürlich
auch hier der Staat das ist die die
Hafen die Hafengesellschaft die behaler
die dafür verantwortlich ist in der
Stadt jetzt probierten aufholeffekt der
letzten zwei Jahre zu machen bei den
Fragen der Mieteinnahmen die entgangen
sind aufgrund der corona-pandemie das
können die Händlerinnen und Händler
nicht stemmen die sind gerade so durch
diese Pandemie gekommen und jetzt wird
ihnen quasi das Rückgrat noch mal mit
diesen Kosten gebrochen und wird
umgelegt ich sage sie müssen mir mal
richtig ran an die Steuer
Steuersenkungen vielleicht auch reiche
mehr belasten
müssen erst einmal wo der Staat in der
Verantwortung ich habe ihn ja heute
alleine in dieser Sendung schon drei
Beispiele gegeben wo der Staat als
handelnder Akteur diese
Preissteigerungen einfach eins zu eins
weitergeben oder die Inflation quasi
nicht ausgleicht obwohl er sie
ausgleichen könnte das ist Aufgabe wo
wir als erstes als Politik rankommen und
da kannst Du schon richtig was drehen
und das hatten Effekt an der Stelle auf
die Birne auf den Apfel auf die Banane
das sind genau die Punkte ich glaube
auch bei Ihnen heute in der Bild dazu
eine entsprechende Berichterstattung
gelesen zu haben und wir sind schon
mittendrin beim Thema Steuern und
heransauer da haben sie einen riesen
Haufen mitgebracht ein bisschen ist
angeschnittenes Thema Steuern aber sie
haben wirklich eine Aufreger mitgebracht
was viele Menschen auch nicht verstehen
und nicht mehr nachvollziehen können es
ist ihre Zeit es ist ihr Thema Ihre
Kamera legen Sie los
zur Abgabe der grundsteuererklärungen
das ist jetzt ein Thema das könnte man
als Exoten Thema abtun er hat auch
nichts zu tun mit den anderen Themen
Migration und work kommen wir auch noch
drauf aber es betrifft trotzdem Dutzende
von Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
und ich bin auch der Bild-Zeitung
dankbar dass das immer wieder schon im
Blatt aufgegriffen worden ist der
Zwangsabgabe von grundsteuererklärungen
für 36 Millionen angeblich das ist die
offizielle Zahl Grundstücke das heißt
nicht dass man so viele Erklärungen
abgeben muss weil für man kann ja wenn
es wirtschaftliche Einheiten sind eine
Erklärung dann für fünf oder zehn
Flurstück Nummern abgeben aber der
Bürokratismus
diese Zumutung die Millionen von
Betroffenen ich schätze mal das sind
bestimmt in Deutschland zu 30 Millionen
25 Millionen werden das sein
was man hier zumutet ist ein Skandal
jetzt habe ich hier mein mitgebracht die
ganzen Formulare im Freistaat Bayern
jetzt ist in Bayern das angeblich noch
relativ einfach
das Grundlagen Formular dann gibt's
natürlich massenhaft Anlagen an Anlage
Grundstück Anlage für Landwirte
Tierbestand Anlage Land und
Forstwirtschaft wobei der Tierbestand
wieder normal Anlage zur dieser Anlage
ist und Anlage Anlage und dann wird es
aber dann wird es aber richtig
interessant zu jedem dieser eins der
Formular gibt es dann Anleitungen es
gibt
10 Seiten eng bedruckte Anleitung zum
grundformular Ausfüllen es gibt 10
Seiten an einer Anleitung zur Anlage
Land und Forstwirtschaft es gibt
seitenanlage Tierbestand es gibt sieben
seitenanlage Grundstück also das sind
die
Anleitungen zur Anlage also schlimmer
will ich gar nicht mehr funktionieren
ein paar Grundstücke wieder
inzwischen ziemlicher Experte geworden
ich habe nämlich den Selbstversuch
gemacht ich habe mir immer in meinem
politischen Leben angewandt das was wir
als politikerzimmer wieder beim Thema
Bodenhaftung oder reales Leben alles was
wir als Politiker den Menschen zumuten
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern am besten an
sich selber mal auszuprobieren wie wirkt
es wie geht es und ich habe mir auch
einen Grundsatz gemacht was ich
niemanden mehr in meiner Bürgerschaft in
meinem Wahlkreis erklären kann in der
Öffentlichkeit dann mache ich politisch
auch nicht mit so und das ist so ein
Beispiel
der Selbstversuch alles probiert das
begann also mit meinem Versuch über
Elstern dieses elektronische Steuer
Dings da nach drei Stunden aufgegeben
man
dann habe ich mich für die Papierform
entschieden und dann mit diesem ganzen
Formularen sich eingearbeitet ich
empfehle immer Papier vor weil da kann
man dann dann haben die Finanzbeamten
nach viel zu tun die haben zum Lesen zu
blättern und dann kann man denen auch
Fußnoten reinschreiben dann können die
also lesen was man Fußnoten
Erläuterungen bei ist da können sie
keine Fußnoten das geht nicht das nimmst
ja nicht an also da kann man da schön
reinschreiben es kommt aber der Oberarm
also die Fristen sind ja schon
verlängert worden von Abgabe 30
September auf 31 Januar ich kann nur
sagen ich fordere eine weitere
Fristverlängerung weil die abgabequote
liegt derzeit so ich glaube und bei
ungefähr 50% nur wir haben jetzt nur
noch zwei Wochen der Oberhammer ist dass
der Bund mit seinen Grundstücken
der muss ja selber der Bund für seine
Grundstücke die bundesligenschaften auch
bei den länderfinanzbehörden diese
grundsteuererklärungen abgeben der Bund
selber gewährt sich eine Abgabefrist
nicht 31 Januar sondern 30 September
diesen Jahres mit der Begründung es sei
alles so kompliziert also das was den
betroffenen Bürgern Millionen von
Bürgern zumutet lässt du für sich selbst
nicht gelten das ist ein echter Skandal
und deswegen sage ich also was für den
Bund Recht ist das muss für die Bürger
billig sein ganz also bei aller
Wertschätzung auch für ihre Arbeit aber
der eigentliche Skandal ist ihr Vortrag
hier denn sie wissen sehr genau
sie brauchen Sie nicht wundern wenn sie
unter 5% fallen hier bei der bei der
Berliner Wahl
lassen Sie mal sachlich darüber sprechen
sachlich sachlich darüber sprechen
wenn wir über diese Frage reden dass sie
hier vortragen dann ist es eine Frage
erstens dass das durch ein Gericht
entschieden wurde hier neue
Grundlage herbeizuführen zweitens ist es
nicht zu lösen es ist doch keine Frage
die die ampelregierung betrifft sondern
ist eine Frage die durch ein Gericht
entschieden wurde
eine neue Bemessung so und deshalb macht
es ja keinen Sinn das zu einem
politischen Skandal Thema zu machen und
dass ich daran so auf zu reden sondern
die Frage ist wie kriegen das gelöst
wenn man über Jahre die Digitalisierung
versäumt hat in politischer
Verantwortung sich stolz auf die
Schultern klopf wie lange man im
Deutschen Bundestag Verantwortung hatte
und dann sich an dieser Stelle mit
diesen Fragen auseinandersetzt dann ist
es doch genau das was dazu führt das
Glaubwürdigkeit in die Politik verloren
geht weil wir an dieser Stelle jetzt ein
Thema abzuarbeiten haben was entschieden
wurde gerichtlich was auch durch eine
Koalition in der CDU und CSU beteiligt
waren und Verantwortung hatten gemeinsam
Regierung gebildet haben mit der SPD
entsprechend verabredet worden ist das
so umzusetzen das wird jetzt durch einen
Ministerium abgearbeitet aber doch
deshalb nicht so ja aber die
Digitalisierung stand doch still in
unserem Land in den letzten 16 Jahren da
muss doch jetzt erstmal richtig
Modernisierung reinkommen und deshalb
verlangen wir die Fristen und deshalb
ist der Digitalisierung
der Digitalisierung ja aber und es ist
auch eine Frage dass wir ein
Gerichtsurteil dahinter haben ja klar
was machen
zurückgeschossen und sie müssen ein
bisschen Lindner verteidigen es geht mir
doch hier gar nicht um die Frage wer im
Augenblick Bundesfinanzminister ist ich
schätze Christen sondern es geht um was
Grundsätzliches dahinter es geht darum
ja dass die Frage der Digitalisierung
die sie ja auch gerade angesprochen
haben hier das Stapel Papier in die
Kamera gehalten ist ja etwas was über
Jahre in unserem Land versäumt worden
ist da müssen wir doch aber selbst wenn
das alles digital ist dann dann bleibt
ja doch noch diese Arbeit für die viele
Bürger überhaupt nicht genau deshalb gab
es schon mal eine Fristverlängerung und
wenn das nicht auch bei verlängerten
Fristen was machen denn ältere Leute
riesen Thema Fachkraft für Gesundheit
und sozialdienstleistungen und ich habe
viele ältere Leute in der Betreuung die
kommen mit ihrer Rente gerade so aus die
können hier Häuschen gerade irgendwie so
kriegen sie das über die Runden ja und
können nur existieren weil sie keine
Miete bezahlen müssen die können dazu
irgendeinem Steuerberaterin und können
den drei vier 500 € in werfen damit das
ausgefüllt wird ich glaube nicht dass
die natalisierung die Lösung das Problem
eventuell vielleicht auch die
Grundsteuer nicht bezahlt das bedeutet
die Frage der Digitalisierung ist gerade
angesprochen weil die Frage wie viel
Papier habe ich da eigentlich gerade vor
mir was muss ich da alles ausfüllen geht
das nicht einfacher sie haben es ja
gerade gesagt was funktioniert da gut
bei Elster und was nicht wie ist dieses
System aufgestellt ist eine Frage der
technischen ist natürlich tatsächlich
die das dass man das andere ist dass das
politisch jetzt auf Grundlage eines
Gerichtsurteils neu verhandelt werden
musste was SPD CSU und CDU entsprechend
umgesetzt dafür verantwortlich und das
interessiert auch nicht
ich mache mir geht's dabei noch um einen
Punkt deswegen habe ich es vorhin so
gesagt ich sage das ist ja das ist eine
riesen Thema ist auch eine
Herausforderung deshalb wurden ja auf
Fristen verlängert das was mich dabei
nur ärgert ist wenn Sie sich hier
hinsetzen bei aller Wertschätzung ich
war so freundlich habe das gesagt auch
ernst gemeint dass sie das so zu einem
Skandal hochschieben weil wir müssen das
hintereinander kriegen ich habe gesagt
der passt
momentan bei sechs bis sieben Prozent
gehört ich wünsche Ihnen ja dass sie
reinkommen der bürgerliche ordentliche
Anteile in Berlin auch andere Frage nein
ich sage es ist Skandal dass der Staat
für sich selber sonder Fristen einräumt
und den normalen Bürgern die die zügeln
anliegt aber bitte natürlich
Digitalisierung haben wir viel zu wenig
wenn das funktioniert würde dann
bräuchte es diese
Aufhebens gar nicht weil
Ämter eigentlich sollte man überall
reinschreiben Daten liegen in Ihrem
Hause vor Daten liegen in Ihrem Hause
vor alle Daten die man da rein schreibt
liegen eigentlich in den
Finanzverwaltungen vor die müssen nur
richtig verknüpft werden und weil die
Verwaltungen eben mangels
Digitalisierung darum haben sie in dem
Punkt recht sage ich ja auch mangels
Digitalisierung ist das nicht möglich
diese Verknüpfung aber diese Last dann
bei den Bürgern abzuladen alte Menschen
die kommen zu mir auch ins Abgeordneten
Büro bitte helfen sie mir wir hatten
und dann müssen wir doch helfen
sollten auch für die normalen Menschen
geht dafür einsetzen
september und dann hat man noch mal ein
bisschen Zeit ich nehme das heute mal
als Thema mit ah damals aber schnell
geeignet
ganz ganz messbare Ergebnisse ich möchte
trotzdem auch generell noch mal bei dem
Thema Steuern bleiben weil viele die
sich jetzt mit diesen Unterlagen gerade
herumschlagen fangen sich dennoch und
die Steuer und schon wieder die Steuer
und da sind wir wieder bei dem Thema
dass die Mitte immer mehr das Gefühl hat
ich zahle umso mehr die Taschen sind
voll oder hält teuer die steuerkassen es
läuft doch eigentlich super ja aber da
haben wir auch wieder das Problem der
Bürokratie der ja also das vielleicht
muss die Bürokratie auch mal angeschoben
werden damit sie etwas besser läuft ja
dieses weil wie gesagt haben haben wir
schon immer so gemacht machen wir nicht
mehr anders dass das einfach nicht mehr
geht ja und dass man sich dann nicht auf
seinem Sessel ausruhen kann sondern
genau die Geschwindigkeit die eben jetzt
auch vorgelegt worden ist bei unseren
energienöten dass die auch in anderen
Bereichen erstmal das Ziel sein soll und
nichts anderes wir brauchen diesen
Modernisierung an vielen Stellen und das
ist ein Beispiel dafür wo er wo er
trinkt notwendig ist und ähm wo wir
jetzt nicht noch mehr Zeit verlieren
dürfen ja und sie sehen ja einen anderen
Ländern sie können sich bisher überall
anschauen sind ja auch viel unterwegs
gewesen woander Patricia und dann stelle
ich mir natürlich mit meinen 39 Jahren
und wenig
politiklaufzeit bisher die Frage wieso
geht es da und bei uns nicht und geht
dem nach und sage Mensch ja das muss und
die kriegen wir haben ja positiv
Beispiele in unserem Land deshalb habe
ich ja vorhin einmal so plakativ gesagt
bei lngh hat es funktioniert und die
Geschwindigkeit muss auch die Vorgabe
sein ne was machen Sie jetzt mit ihrem
Antrag wenn die Unterlagen jetzt alle
eingereicht oder wie geht es jetzt bei
Ihnen weiter weiter
Abgabe fertig und unterschrieben liegt
alles bereit und wird demnächst abgelegt
also das sind sozusagen nicht die
original unterwegs
zu lesen und ich habe Reihe von vielen
in den Anleitungen entdeckt die ich an
die
Verwaltung der Stelle schon weiter
gereicht habe zu Verbesserung ich bin
auch da sehr hilfreich sein wie schaffen
wir bei dem zukünftigen hinter der
Fragen bei den die sie jetzt ansprechen
wenn es um die Frage Grundsteuer wird
wie können wir
grunderwerbsteuerfreibetrag in unserem
Land einführen für die selbst- und
erstgenutzte Immobilie die man erwirbt
von drei bis 400.000 Euro beispielsweise
Grunderwerbsteuer also die
Grundsatzfragen dahinter in der in der
Steuerpolitik die müssen wir genauso
angehen wie die Frage denn
Mietkosten Berlin glaube ich auch
gründerwerbsteuer
6,5%, das könnten sie Benzin die
Regierung kommen gleich mehr
runtersetzen auf das bayerische Niveau
3,5%
bei 810%. in der Stadt die zu halbieren
bei der Frage der Grundsteuer haben wir
sogar gegen finanziert im Landeshaushalt
und haben gesagt dann wären wir auf dem
Bundesdurchschnitt werden doch nicht
ganz bei Bayern aber würden sehr nah
dran kommen und damit eine Entlastung in
der Breite im Übrigen für jeden der in
in der Stadt in einer Mietwohnung oder
im Eigentum wohnt in der Blauwale
ja also haben wir vorgeschlagen in der
Frage Steuerpolitik sie sehen ich kann
in Berlin nicht wählen also
[Gelächter]
Überforderungen gesprochen viele
Kommunen schreien derzeit SOS winken SOS
Überforderungen mit der Zahl der
Flüchtlinge die ins Land kommen das ist
ihr großes Thema denn sie glauben dieses
Thema wurde noch nicht genug erkannt
ihre Zeit ja ich mache ja Zeit über 30
Jahren ehrenamtlich Flüchtlingshilfe und
konnte somit auch die Entwicklung
verfolgen wie damals im ehemaligen
Jugoslawien der Krieg ausgebrochen ist
da war ja die Haltung der damaligen
Bundesregierung eine ganz andere da
wollte man gar keine Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen dann hat man sich für 10.000
bereit erklärt Schluss letztendlich
waren es 265.000 die gekommen sind aber
es war klar diese Menschen kommen weil
jetzt eben dort Krieg ist und man
versorgt sie und wenn der Krieg zu Ende
ist gehen Sie zurück und man hilft beim
Aufbau des Landes das ist auch so
passiert 65000 sind also hier geblieben
weil sie eben in Arbeit oder Ausbildung
waren
wie
2015/2016 die flüchtlingskrise losging
habe ich das schon mit großen
Bauchschmerzen gesehen weil
wir klar war wir haben Bilder die
Manpower noch haben wir die die
Voraussetzung diese Menschen adäquat zu
versorgen und die Frau Dr Merkel hat es
ja sehr schlau gemacht die hat ja immer
gesagt geschaffen das sie hat aber nie
festgelegt was schaffen wir und wie
damals die Flüchtlinge so an den
Bahnhöfen begrüßt worden sind von von
einigen Bürgern wie Popstars also
wirklich die waren ja völlig euphorisch
und ähm da wurden meine Bauchschmerzen
noch größer weil mir war klar das sind
nicht die Leute die hinterher helfen
diese Menschen hier auch ankommen zu
lassen zu integrieren und
nachhaltig in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
zu holen und es ist völlig in die Hose
gegangen das muss man ganz klar sagen
letztes Jahr sind 44% aller Asylanträge
abgelehnt worden das ist einfach voll
gegessen dass die Menschen hier völlig
unkontrolliert ins Land dass es vorher
überhaupt nicht geprüft wird gibt es
Asylgründe oder nicht
auch diese 44 Prozent die abgelehnt
wurden bleiben trotzdem hier mit einer
Duldung das heißt diese Menschen leben
in Gemeinschaftsunterkünften immer mit
ja sie könnten theoretisch jederzeit
abgeschoben werden was aber in der
Realität nicht passiert also es werden
im Schnitt so 15 Prozent nur wirklich
auch dann in die Heimatländer
zurückgeschickt es ist ein riesen Thema
und wenn man überlegt dass jetzt im
Moment ja nicht nur durch den Ukraine
Krieg wieder sehr viele Menschen
gekommen sind
sondern auch so 30.000 Flüchtlinge jeden
Monat nach Deutschland kommen und die
wollen auch immer sehr gerne explizit
nach Deutschland das ist auch einfach so
dann ja bereitet mir das schlaflose
Nächte das kann ich schon so sagen jetzt
muss man dazu sagen Frau schneid sie
waren selbst auch Flüchtlingshelferin
haben sie immer noch ich bin's halt
mittlerweile Club 33 Jahren
ehrenamtliche Flüchtlingshelferin auch
heute noch als Plakat gestern erst
wieder in der Unterkunft und habe viele
Menschen nachhaltig integriert also eine
flüchtlingsfrau die 2015 aus Syrien
gekommen ist es heute meine
Kundenberaterin bei der Sparkasse wollte
ich noch mal an der Stelle sagen auch
das gibt es aber das ist nicht die Regel
und das müssen wir ganz klar sagen das
ist im Gegenteil die Ausnahme stellen
Sie uns einmal was sie in ihrem Ehrenamt
beobachten und wo sie für sich ganz
persönlich erkannt haben so können wir
das nicht machen so geht das nicht
weiter hier muss ich was ändern das muss
ich alles ändern also unsere ganze
Asylpolitik ist einfach eine Katastrophe
und ähm wir müssen anfangen zu
unterscheiden holen wir wirklich
Menschen aus Kriegsgebieten hierher die
alles recht haben wirklich hier zu sein
oder unterstützen wir weiterhin
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge und ein ganz
großer Teil der Menschen die kommen sind
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge und das ist ein
Problem
denn diese Menschen kommen hierher weil
einfach die Anreize die wir hier haben
sehr sehr hoch sind wir haben ja
wirklich noch sehr gut funktionierendes
Sozialsystem und das ist einfach ein
sehr hoher Anreiz und deswegen kommen
die Menschen auch ganz gezielt hierher
und wollen eben nicht in einem der
Länder bleiben durch die sie reisen das
ist einfach so
und man muss einfach glaube ich diesen
diesen Flüchtlings Tourismus der also
entstanden ist den müsste man eindämmen
das ist genauso wie ich habe ja viele
auch aus der Ukraine viele Familien die
ukrainische Menschen aufgenommen haben
die mich irgendwann total entsetzt
angerufen haben gesagt ist der Krieg
vorbei in der Ukraine und ich sag nein
warum ja die sind jetzt in Urlaub
gefahren die haben Bus gebucht die
fahren jetzt drei Wochen in die Ukraine
die machen da Urlaub und das sind
natürlich so Dinge sowieso dann den
Menschen ganz schlecht erklären kannst
ja die vorher alles dafür getan haben um
diesen Menschen eine gewisse Sicherheit
hier zu bieten ja und
ich weiß nicht warum wir diese
Flüchtlingspolitik betreiben
es ist wir haben so gut wie keine
wirklichen flüchtlingshelfer also es
lastet alles auf uns ehrenamtlichen und
auch die werden immer weniger und die
Menschen sind auf sich alleine gestellt
die Parallelgesellschaften werden immer
größer
die haben so Fahrt aufgenommen dass es
wirklich erschreckend ist
sie eine Erklärung dafür dass die
Politik diese Menschen im Stich lässt
auch sie werden in ihrer Arbeit
öffentlich Helferinnen
ich glaube schon dass Deutschland sehr
viel tut übrigens auch im sehr privaten
Bereich um gerade ukrainische
Flüchtlinge Kriegsflüchtlinge ja
natürlich klar also ich habe in der
letzten Sendung als ich hier war auch
die Frage gestellt wie da war das Haus
hier ein
migrationswissenschaftler ich habe den
als Wirtschaftswissenschaftler den
migrationswissenschaften die Frage
gestellt wie er ist erklärt dass das war
also
an dem Zeitpunkt gerade so dass paar
Tage später ich habe das Recherchieren
lassen allein aus Berlin 32 flixbusse
nach
Kiew gefahren sind also das ist das was
sie jetzt auch genau er hat es dann auch
erklärt warum die dahin fahren und
wieder zurück und so weiter die fahren
auch dann wieder her aber ich meine das
ist sie steht da schon voll dahinter
dass diesen Menschen geholfen wird
und dass die Kinder die da kommen
ordentliche Grundschule Ausbildung oder
Schulausbildung wahnsinnige
Anforderungen auch an unsere Lehrkräfte
sagenhaft was da abgefordert wird und
man schafft hier auch bei den
Jugendlichen und Kindern die aus der
Ukraine heute hier sind die dann wieder
zurückgehen auch ein Stück Deutschland
Verbundenheit das hat auch langfristige
positive Folgen in Deutschland
muss dort wo es zerstört ist auch wieder
aufgebaut werden das heißt ich gehe mal
davon aus dass die meisten davon auch
wieder zurückgehen
festlegen weil die Ukraine ist nur ein
Beispiel also wir haben ja viele
Flüchtlinge aus Afghanistan
geben sie würden aus Syrien kommen
das sind ja Sachen die begleiten mich
seit über 30 Jahren die Ukraine ist
jetzt ein kleiner Teil und das ist
sicherlich schwer den Menschen
begreiflich zu machen wieso fahren die
in Kriegsgebiete das machen aber im
übrigen andere Flüchtlinge auch
das ist jetzt kein ukraine-problem aber
Fakt ist natürlich auch dass wir hier
wir haben unsere ärztliche Versorgung
steht vor dem absoluten Kollaps ja also
ich sage Ihnen was ich habe mir jetzt
ein Hautarzttermin gemacht den habe ich
jetzt im September 2025 das ist kein
Witz ja ich stehe bei meiner Hausärztin
da steht eine Frau weinend an der an der
Anmeldung und sagt ihr Hausarzt ist
jetzt geht jetzt zum eintresten 12 in
Ruhestand und sie findet keinen neuen
Hausarzt also wir haben bei uns in der
Stadt 12 Hausärzte und keine nimmt neue
Patienten auf weil alle am Limit sind ja
heute morgen habe ich gerade bevor ich
hierher gefahren bin erfahren dass eine
gute Bekannte von mir verstorben ist ja
einem Herzinfarkt weil sie vier Wochen
auf einen Kardiologen Termin gewartet
hat obwohl der Hausarzt sie schon als
Notfall angemeldet hat das ist die
Realität und ähm wir haben überhaupt
nicht mehr die Strukturen noch mehr
Menschen aufzunehmen wir haben weder die
Wohnungen noch haben wir die kinderbe
Plätze noch haben wir die ärztliche
Versorgung wir haben sie nicht ja und es
ist für mich unbegreiflich wenn ich sehe
dass 44% der Asylanträge abgelehnt
worden sind wenn ich sehe dass Experten
wie die flüchtlingskrise im Jahr 2015
begonnen hat haben die hochgerechnet wie
viel Sozialwohnungen müssen wir zur
Verfügung stellen um das zu stemmen und
diese Experten haben hochgerechnet dass
wir bis ins Jahr 2022 jedes Jahr 240.000
Sozialwohnungen hätten bauen müssen es
ist nicht passiert und ja aber gut dass
du das das Problem ist ja nicht nur die
wie geht man um mit Flüchtlingen sondern
das Problem ist dass es tatsächlich
keine
Einwanderungspolitik aus einem Guss gibt
eine Katastrophen brauchen wir
Arbeitskräfte völlig klar
ganz ehrlich also ich sage immer was wie
es damals geheißen hat jetzt kommen die
Fachkräfte ich bin auch Deutsch lernen
für geflüchtete da habe ich mich gefragt
okay Katja hast du jetzt nur die
Analphabeten abbekommen also ich habe
mit den angefangen des Alphabet zu
lernen und wie dann die ersten Zahlen
der Arbeitsagentur kamen die besagt
haben dass fast 80 Prozent der Menschen
weder eine Ausbildung noch ein
Schulabschluss haben da ist das die
Realität und wenn man jetzt sieht das
von 2015 die Leute die gekommen sind ja
70 Prozent habe ich heute noch habe ich
heute noch in den
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften sitzen mit
mangelnden Sprachkenntnissen leben von
Sozialhilfe und es hat also es ist eine
Katastrophe da ist nichts mit
Fachkräften zwei Seiten es gelingt uns
offensichtlich nicht tatsächlich
hochmotivierte und gut qualifizierte
Menschen nach Deutschland zu holen das
ist eine es gelingt uns aber nicht
qualifizierte Menschen hierher zu holen
und sobald jemand sagt genau gibt es
hier eine ganze Reihe von Organisationen
die alles dafür tun dass diese Person
bleibt so lange sie möchte und an beiden
Seiten hakt es ja es hat daran
tatsächlich die Leute Deutschland
attraktiv zu machen für die Leute die
wir wirklich brauchen und auf der
anderen Seite vielleicht nicht so
attraktiv zu machen für die Leute die
wir nicht brauchen und die aber auch
nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Schutz
Bedürfnis ist ja wie gesagt die Anreize
sind ja auch so hoch wie soll ich denn
einer Familie guck mal
Flüchtlingsfamilie zwei Kinder bekommen
an Mietzahlung Sozialleistungen brauchen
kein Kindergartenplatz zu bezahlen keine
Zusagen sind roundabout ungefähr 1800
Euro netto die sie zur Verfügung haben
mit Miete wie gesagt mit
Kindergartenplätze jetzt will ich stehen
für Mindestlohn den Papa Arbeiten
schicken und dann würde der heimkommen
und hätte noch 1400 da zeigt mir doch
ein Vogel der sagt wenn ich hier in
Deutschland gar nichts mache ich habe
1800 und wenn ich jetzt 40 Stunden die
Woche arbeiten gehe ich komme mit 1400
nach Hause nein das ist ein Problem ist
auch in Bayern
seit dieser Woche können Sie das doch
heute nach Hause seit 650 Einwohner ist
eine große Geschichte im Bayerischen
Rundfunk gewesen ist in der Nähe von
Schrobenhausen dieses Dorf und dort gibt
es schlägt der Bürgermeister dieser
Alarm 50 geflüchtete Menschen sind dort
und seitdem kann dieses Dorf steht für
wahnsinnig vielen Problemen und fühlt
sich alleine gelassen der Bürgermeister
nannte Beispiele das ist eine
Trauerfeier sie kennen das kennen Sie
pointenhaus sie haben diese Geschichte
gehört
ich kenne dieses einzeldorf
nein ich kenne das Problem aus der
Praxis
meine beiden Landräte Bernhard Kern im
Berchtesgadener Land und Siegfried Wald
im Landkreis Traunstein ja die berichten
mir beinahe täglich über die Probleme
die wir haben jetzt am letzten
Wochenende habe ich wieder mit beiden
gesprochen die sagen wir schaffen es
also jede Woche werden pro Landkreis 50
Flüchtlinge einfach zugewiesen einfach
zu wie gesagt
das geht so nicht mehr weiter aber die
Regierung von Oberbayern sagt
ihr kriegt die auf dem Hof gestellt jede
Woche 50 das sind auch alle
familientyp-typen Zusammensetzungen
dabei irgendwie müsst ihr brauchen bis
jetzt sagen die Leute haben das gerade
noch geschafft ohne die Beschlagnahmung
und Nutzung von schulternhallen aber
irgendwann ist der Punkt überschritten
und dann sie haben völlig richtig gesagt
oder waren sie wir Angela Merkel gesagt
wir schaffen
gesagt
in der Bevölkerung wenn dann die nicht
mehr genutzt werden sogar höhere Zahlen
nur sprechen wir weniger drüber das ist
das ist der Punkt und berichten darüber
natürlich auch ein Teil des Ganzen
Problems dass wir Probleme so lange
unter Teppich kehren bis wieder
irgendjemand sie aussieht höchste Frage
die mir bringen gestellt wird wenn neue
Flüchtlinge kommen ist tatsächlich wann
bekomme ich denn Haus und ich habe das
irgendwann angefangen zu hinterfragen
und das ist tatsächlich die Verdiener
die Schleuser sind ja nach wie vor aktiv
die erzählen den Leuten die darüber du
kriegst jeden Monat 1000 Euro du kriegst
ein Haus die wollen dich die warten auf
Dich und ich habe also schon so oft
appelliert auch an die Regierung endlich
Informationspolitik zu betreiben ja und
den Leuten wissen Sie diese diese
Flüchtlinge die sind ja die sind ja auch
Opfer das darf man nicht vergessen die
bekommen in ihren Herkunftsländern die
tollsten Sachen von Deutschland erzählt
die Schlepper die die gehen teilweise
her die die Mütter verkaufen ihren
Familien Schmuck damit die Schlepper
bezahlt werden können nach wie vor ja da
hat sich überhaupt nichts dran geändert
und dann kommen die hierher und finden
sich plötzlich in irgendeine
Gemeinschaftsunterkunft wieder die
schämen sich zu Tode und ich habe immer
gesagt warum transportieren die diese
Informationen nicht in ihr Herkunftsland
damit eben nicht noch mehr nachkommt die
schämen sich und dann gehen die her wenn
die im Monats anfangen hier ihr Geld
bekommen ihre Sozialhilfe hat vier und
dann legen die das meinen Haufen 3 4 5
Leute und fotografieren das sind ja in
den Herkunftsländer ist das ja unfassbar
viel Geld und das sind die Bilder die
die in ihre Herkunftsländer schicken
damit die Familien beruhigt sind ja und
weil sie sich schämen ihn die Realität
zu sagen und ich habe schon so oft an
die Regierung appelliert und habe gesagt
bitte bitte betreibt eine transparente
Informationspolitik in den
Herkunftsländern damit die Leute nicht
mehr auf diese Schlepper reinfallen und
wissen was sie hier erwartet das ist zum
Beispiel eine ganz konkrete Forderung
eine transparente Informationspolitik
auch aus den Herkunftsländer wir haben
jetzt viele Beispiele hier gehört ihre
Regierung ich habe öfter schon in der
Sendung gesagt sie sitzt in ihre Partei
sitzt in der Regierung das entgegen sie
in der Tat wir sitzen seit
2021 in der Regierung hier in
im Bund und ich will das noch mal
sortieren das Lagebild weil wir haben
natürlich die Situation dass wir eine
Einwanderungspolitik zielgerichtet
gesteuert machen müssen dafür brauchen
wir aber eine gute
Einwanderungspolitik in der Frage der
Integrationspolitik in der Frage sie
haben das so schön vorhin auch noch mal
rechtlich dargestellt ne Schutz suchen
Asyl wer ist ähm Asyl Empfänger ist
alles im Gesetz geregelt aber alles was
im Gesetz geregelt ist heißt eben auch
dass jemanden ordentliches Asylverfahren
durchläuft und wenn das Gesetz zu der
Auffassung kommt dass dieser Status
nicht vorhanden ist dann heißt es eben
auch dass für ein funktionierenden
Rechtsstaat es dann heißen muss dass wir
an den Stellen und wir haben sie gerade
in Berlin mit der Frage auch
zurückzuführen der Moldavia dann
entsprechend die Rückführung nachdem ein
ordnungsgemäßes
Rechtsverfahren durchlaufen wurde auch
vollzogen wird
dass wir das einmal sortieren da wo wir
regeln Regelwerk haben anwenden darum
Regelwerk das ist anders
die nicht sichereren
zweitens dass wir die Frage beantworten
wie können wir Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt besser organisieren das
muss dringend angegangen werden mein
Eindruck ist dass die Bundesregierung an
dieser Frage ernsthaft auch arbeitet
dass das besser wird mit klarem Regeln
und mit klaren Prioritäten hier auch und
das andere sind die die Krisenherde die
wir in äh auf der Welt haben wo ich
glaube hier Konsens ist und sie haben es
ja gerade auch noch mal gesagt mit Blick
auf die jüngste Krise mit dem
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine hier
entsprechend Asyl zu gewähren
zu ermöglichen und ich kenne das hier
aus der Stadt Berlin hier sind 360.000
Ukrainerinnen an Ukraine angekommen
360.000
davon sind 100.000 in der Stadt
geblieben und nach meinem Kenntnisstand
sind davon etwa 70 bis 80.000 privat
untergekommen der Rest in staatlichen
Einrichtung des zeigt wie groß und auch
wie dankbar wir sein können auch für die
Arbeit die sie im übrigen leisten dass
wir Integration und Flüchtlingshilfe
hier machen und das kann nur mittel und
langfristig gelingen wenn der Staat da
wo er Gesetze hat sie auch anwendet und
tatsächlich damit den Rechtsrahmen den
er hat auch ausschöpft nur dann kann das
gelingen was sie auch beschrieben haben
und da müssen wir müssen wir in der Tat
besser werden da muss man sogar ran das
ist ein Thema wir haben uns hier gerade
im Dezember die Frage auf der wohl da
wir präsentiert es müssen einfach gucken
Sie mal ich begleite Asylverfahren
15 Jahre
15 Jahre wo Menschen in
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften sitzen die
nicht privat ziehen dürfen weil sie
könnten
Situation abgeschoben werden könnten das
heißt die dürfen kein Eigentum besitzen
das sind Kinder die sind in die sind in
anderthalb Zimmern mit Gemeinschaftsklo
und Abschiebungen und Kriminalität
durcheinander
gehen Supervision also wenn ich einfach
merke da sind ja Schicksale dabei die
auch für mich sehr belasten sind weil
natürlich wenn du dich kümmerst über
viele Jahre da entstehen ja auch enge
Bindungen ja und ich konzentriere mich
ja tatsächlich auf die Menschen die
wollen ja also diese sag mal wirklich 10
bis 15% haben wir ja die wirklich wollen
so und auf die konzentriere ich mich und
natürlich hast du deine Bindung zu den
Menschen und wenn ich sehe das 15 Jahre
ein Kind niemanden aus dem aus dem
Kindergarten oder der Schule zu sich
nach Hause einlädt nie ein
Kindergeburtstag feiern weil es einfach
so schön für diese ärmlichen Verhältnis
ein bisschen runtergekommenen
flüchtlingsunterkünften und das muss man
auch mal sagen die meisten haben ja
immer das Bild von wir haben hier neue
tolle Flüchtlingsunterkünfte gebaut das
ist auch nicht richtig also es gibt
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte da würde ich
nicht mal meinen Hund drin unterbringen
geschweige denn irgendein Mensch sie
sprechen einen Punkt dieses Verfahren da
muss man ganz kurz und da muss man auch
ganz klar sagen die Vermieter diese
Unterkünfte die verdienen sich dumm und
blöd die verdienen mit so einem alten
abbruchreifenhaus und der Umständen
20.000 € im Monat diese vom Kreis
bezahlt bekommen weil sie nämlich pro
Person Geld bekommen und da werden
einfach Unmengen an Leute dort
untergebracht und kein Mensch
kontrolliert ist das ist auch eine
Realität und wenn Sie einen
Asylverfahren haben was wirklich über 15
Jahre sich zieht ja und sie sehen so ein
Mädchen ich meine ist heute sie ist
verheiratet sie hat es großen Augen
Außenhandelskauffrau sie erbaut gerade
ein Haus also angekommen diese Familie
hier dann stellst du dir schon die Frage
was passiert hier und es ist auch eine
Forderungen unsere Politik wo ich ganz
klar sage
kein Asylverfahren darf länger dauern
wie sechs Monate wenn ich einen Menschen
fünf sechs Jahre hier geduldet habe den
kann ich doch gar nicht mehr
zurückschicken das geht doch gar nicht
da hat doch den Anschluss schon längst
eine Lösung ja Beschleunigung der
Verfahren das heißt aber auch sechs
Monate maximal auszustatten das da
scheint mir eines der Probleme zu sein
dass ich da die da die Verfahren
man hat sogar Richter aus dem Ruhe
360.000
diese diese langen Verfahren mit einer
mit Ketten Duldungen und so wo das
letztendlich zugeführt hat unklare ähm
unklarer Status sehen wir hier an den
klaren unter anderem in Berlin das sind
alles Leute die hätten auch ein anderes
Schicksal haben können da hat auch
natürlich Bürokratie dass ihre dazu
getan also Beschleunigung von Verfahren
die Integration auch ernst zu nehmen ja
damit uns damit wir uns nicht dran
gewöhnen dass sowas wie
öfter passiert da heißt es aber auch
noch mal in Behörden zu investieren auch
in die Polizei zu investieren das wäre
auch noch mal eine Maßnahme und
ansonsten ich unterstütze das auch
Informationspolitik anders kann das
nicht sein dass sich nicht jeder auf den
Weg macht nur weil ihm irgendein
Schlepper oder verwandter irgendwas
erzählt hat vielleicht sogar sein Leben
dabei verliert es ist ja auch gefährlich
diese Fluchtroute also das da Klarheit
tatsächlich zu schaffen und dann haben
wir den die große Baustelle
Rückführungen ja woran scheitern
Rückführungen natürlich einerseits daran
dass Leuten auch von Hilfsorganisationen
die ganzen Tricks verraten werden wie
man dem entgehen kann der gibt es ja
viele aber natürlich auch die ähm
Klassifizierung von Staaten als unsicher
also wir haben Krisenherde ohne Ende auf
der Welt wir werden nicht alle
Krisenherde als unsichere
staatenklassifizieren können das würde
nämlich bedeuten nehmen alle Leute auf
die in irgendeiner Weise in schlechteren
Lebensverhältnissen sind das ist ja eine
schlechterdings nicht möglich und
Rückführungsabkommen mit bestimmten
Ländern da muss man glaube ich auch noch
mal ein bisschen nachlegen dass Länder
bereit sind ihre Leute wieder
zurückzunehmen die sie exportieren ja
meine wir haben ja auch zum Teil ein
regelrechten staatlichen Export von
Menschen
starten die damit rechnen dass sie von
den Zahlungen derjenigen die ins Ausland
gegangen sind das davon die Wirtschaft
wohnte in vielen Ländern ist das ja
wirklich eine Größe zahlreiche
Vorschläge die Herr Chaya auch mitnimmt
auch offene Worte Probleme benennen
genau das wollen wir hier in dieser
Sendung und damit machen wir auch gleich
weiter kurze Pause bei viertel nach acht
wir freuen uns wenn Sie bei uns bleiben
Probleme benennen damit man sie lösen
kann das machen wir immer seltener das
sagen sie Frau Schröter oder sie war
auch schon mittendrin in ihrem Thema
Probleme offen benennen offen sprechen
ja setz dich mal gleich an an das Thema
was wir eben hatten Silvester ja
darf man danach fragen welchen
Hintergrund diejenigen hatten die
randaliert haben die die
Sicherheitskräfte auch die Sanitäter
angegriffen haben ist das stadthaft oder
ist das rassistisch wie ja viele
Vertreter linker Organisationen und auch
Parteien gesagt haben darf man nach dem
Migrationshintergrund fragen darf man
ihn benennen oder fällt das unter den
Bereich Tabu und womit ich mich
beschäftige ist die zunehmende
Tabuisierung von
Themen die umstritten sind ja wir haben
ja viele Themen zu denen es
unterschiedliche und auch sehr
unterschiedliche Meinungen gibt
Migration ist eines dieser Themen
Islamismus wären anderes mit dem habe
ich mich lange lange Zeit beschäftigt
aber auch Klima Umwelt
Energieversorgung das sind alles Themen
zu denen kann man sehr unterschiedliche
Meinungen haben und was ich aber
zunehmend beobachte anstatt dass man
tatsächlich einen Tisch setzen sagt so
und wo sind da jetzt die Maximalposition
und wo treffen wir uns in der Mitte das
bestimmte Themen automatisch auf einer
tabu-liste landen
zum Beispiel das Thema Migration sie
finden an der Universität kaum noch
Forschungen zu den Schattenseiten von
Migration wenn Sie den Begriff
Parallelgesellschaft
Kultur Islamismus verwenden dann sind
sie kriegen sie keinen Forschungsgeld
dann sind sie sozusagen kaltgestellt
aber das betrifft ja nicht nur
Wissenschaft das betrifft auch die ganz
der Bevölkerung ich stelle immer wieder
fest dass Leute sagen darf ich das jetzt
eigentlich noch sagen habe ich jetzt den
falschen Begriff verwendet ist das ein
Thema wo mich vielleicht jetzt jemand
als Nazi beschimpft oder als Rassist
beschimpft oder als Transport oder es
gibt so ein paar Begrifflichkeiten die
Menschen schon unsicher sind und in der
Tat ich beobachte das ja als
Wissenschaftlerin es gibt ganze
Abhandlungen was man alles nicht mehr
sagen darf und was man stattdessen sagen
darf das nicht nur das Gendern das ja
bei den meisten Leuten doch Emotionen
hervorruft sondern es sind auch viele
andere Dinge
Abkürzung von Wörtern die die ersetzt
werden auch im migrationskontext ja wie
oft hat sich der Begriff für Flüchtling
verändert von Asylbewerber zu
Flüchtlingen zu geflüchtete zu Schutz
suchen damit sind wir alles ideologische
Konzepte verbunden und das muss man
einfach wissen damit beschäftige ich
mich und das man da tiefer einsteigt
dann merkt man da gibt es Konzepte die
sind außerordentlich bedenklich ja
bedenklich nämlich weil die Vorstellung
existiert in einigen Köpfen auch der
Linken Politiker aber auch
Wissenschaftler und Kultur schaffender
dass die westliche Gesellschaft von
Grund auf rassistisch sein von Grund auf
eigentlich etwas
verbesserungswürdig ist
und dass die Aufgabe jetzt der Politik
aber auch der Bildungsinstitution darin
besteht dem Westlern und vor allem den
weißen es geht immer nur um weiß es gibt
tatsächlich einen Bereich der nennt sich
critical Wildnis studies das heißt wir
forschen kritisch überweis sein den
weißen ihren Rassismus auszutreiben mit
dem sie geboren sind da gibt es
tatsächlich die Idee man sei damit
geboren und der Begriff den sie bestimmt
alle schon gehört haben lautet
struktureller Rassismus das heißt in der
Struktur der Gesellschaft in den
Institutionen in der Politik in der in
Bildungseinrichtung auch natürlich in
den Organen des Staates besonders in der
Polizei da ist der Rassismus sozusagen
tief verankert und jetzt sind einige
Gutmenschen
woke die sich selber als wach bezeichnen
sind jetzt aufgerufen der Gesellschaft
den Spiegel vorzuhalten und dafür zu
sorgen dass sie ihren Rassismus erkennen
und dazu gehört dann letztendlich auch
das Programm der
Umwandlung der Gesellschaft durch das
Erkennen dann bestimmte Maßnahmen
aufzulegen dass sich da etwas ändert und
da sind wir bei diesem Wogen
Sprachregelung da sind wir bei den
Tabuthemen bestimmte Dinge dürfen nicht
mehr angesprochen werden weil sie als
Ausdruck des Rassismus bezeichnet werden
bestimmte Wörter dürfen nicht mehr
verwendet werden und die Liste der
Wörter wird immer länger also wer da
wirklich sensibel ist der hat schon
Angst das merke ich immer wieder auch
bei Kollegen tatsächlich hat schon Angst
tatsächlich Sätze zu formulieren weil
irgendjemand wieder kommen könnte könnte
sagen dann das geht jetzt gar nicht und
letztendlich
läuft die Gesellschaft weil viele
natürlich aussteigen wer kann also nur
Akademiker die sich aus Berufswegen
damit beschäftigen sind überhaupt up to
date dass sie wissen was ist jetzt alles
auf der schwarzen Liste und auf der
weißen Liste äh letztendlich führt es
natürlich dazu dass ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung aussteigt aus dieser ganzen
Debatte und sagt ich kann mich da gar
nicht mehr artikulieren ich weiß noch
gar nicht mehr in welchen Worten ich
meine Kritik fassen soll und ein anderer
Teil ja zieht das einfach durch das
Ergebnis meiner Meinung nach ist
gespaltene Gesellschaft und wenn wir
wissen wollen wohin das führen kann dann
brauchen wir bloß Nachbarländer
anzuschauen indem wir große Rechte
Bewegungen haben und USA beispielsweise
wo die Gesellschaft tatsächlich in zwei
Teile zerfallen ist und ich denke wir
sollten alles tun damit für sowas
verhindern heransauer benutzen sie Worte
die sie vielleicht von zehn Jahren
benutzt haben jetzt nicht mehr und
können Sie sich auch damit anfreunden
dass man jetzt zum Beispiel Gebärende
Person sagt und nicht Mutter ist ihnen
das geläufig oder ist Ihnen das völlig
fremd also das ist eine zweiteilige
Frage zum letzteren Teil
kann ich nur sagen ich kann mich
überhaupt nicht damit anfreunden und zum
ersten Teil Ihrer Frage ich rede und
spreche heute so wie vor zehn Jahren
ich habe mich nie verbiegen lassen und
bin immer gut damit gefahren und ich
glaube jetzt komme ich zum dritten Mal
noch mal zurück zur Frage Bodenhaftung
haben Politiker noch Bodenhaftung also
ich höre täglich in meinen Wahlkreis
hinein 280.000 Menschen ja die würden
mich vom Hof jagen politisch gesehen
wenn ich auf einmal anpasslerisch
wirkmäßig und ähm
betreiben würde und das tue ich nicht
ich rede heute so wie immer und jetzt
auch immer Ton Frau Schröter sagte
gerade sie glaubt das könnte zu einer
Spaltung der Gesellschaft führen sie
gehen glaube ich auch so weit die sagen
würden da da ist fast die Demokratie
schon in Gefahr gehen sie auch soweit
teilen Sie diesen Gedanken heilig voll
und ganz wenn wir die und breite
Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung
verlieren
irgendwo sucht sich das dann einen
Ausweg um die Wähler Zahlen sind danach
irgendwo Heilmittel Stimmzettel und ich
meine die Grundlage was ist die
Grundlage der Demokratie auch historisch
gesehen die Meinungsfreiheit die
Pressefreiheit die Kunstfreiheit
Freiheitsrechte ja also die
Freiheitsrechte sind die Grundlage der
Demokratie wenn wir die einschränken
dann verlieren wir ein Stück weit der
freie Bürger der freie Bürger ist im
Grundgesetz das ist das Subjekt dieses
Staates wenn wir aber jetzt anfangen die
Leute in Gruppen Einzelteil das ist auch
ein Teil des Programms es gibt die
Tätergruppen und es gibt die
Opfergruppen die Opfer sind Minderheiten
je nachdem wer sich gerade mit guter
Unterstützung als Minderheit
positionieren kann hat dann ein
Opferstatus Täter sind immer weiß aber
nicht nur das weil trifft nun mal auch
mehr also weißt du wahrscheinlich
Hierarchisierung ein weißer Mann ist
schon mehr Täter als eine weiße Frau ein
heterosexueller Mann noch mehr ein alter
heterosexueller Mann das sozusagen der
Moderne antreten ja ihre Partei wurde
bei der letzten Bundestagswahl vor allem
von jungen Leuten gewählt sagen
verändern na klar müssen wir uns da
weiterentwickeln sagen sie gebärender
Mensch statt Mutter tun Sie persönlich
sich da vielleicht noch schwer wollen
sie sich daran gewöhnen und können es
nicht oder gehen Sie das ab
in ihrem Beitrag wo haben sie ja auch
auf ein Problem hingewiesen gerade was
davon gesellschaftlich ausgeht die Frage
ob wir
überhaupt noch Grautöne zulassen in der
Debatte ob wir wir zeichnen in vielen
Stellen nur noch Schwarz und Weiß und
ich glaube dass wir gerade wenn wir die
Demokratie wieder stärken wollen wenn
wir verhindern wollen dass extreme stark
werden sowohl am rechten als auch am
linken Rand da bin ich bei einem
Ramsauer müssen wir in dieser unserer
Zeit das zulassen dass man miteinander
diskutiert das macht unsere Demokratie
stark dass man Position und Meinung hat
und dass man sich die Position und
Meinung des anderen auch anhört dass man
sie auch bis einem gewissen Maße erträgt
auch das gehört dazu und daraus sich
etwas entwickelt damit wir eben nicht
immer mehr an Politikverdrossenheit
erleben und das beste Beispiel für mich
ist das politische Handeln innerhalb der
corona-pandemie wo wir vieles nicht mehr
politisch erklären konnten und probiert
wurde vieles abzutun entweder bis zu der
für oder dagegen aber es gab nichts
dazwischen in der Frage kann man nicht
vielleicht doch Freiheitsgrundrechte und
Gesundheitsschutz in Einklang bringen
die Debatte war in einer gewissen Phase
überhaupt nicht zugänglich oder erlaubt
und da haben wir ja statistisch ganz
klar hinterlegt bekommen dass das ein
großen Absatz einen großen weglauf an
Vertrauen von Politik gemacht hat mit
den Menschen wo Gerichte Entscheidung
korrigiert haben weil der Plenarsaal
außer Kraft gesetzt wurde und nur noch
Regierung ist immer wieder zurück in der
Pandemie ich wollte mal über die Sprache
reden
weil das ist der Kern um den es für mich
hier geht ähm und das ist das ist
wichtig ich werde Mutter sagen wenn Sie
darauf hin wenn jemand sagt wenn jemand
sagen möchte Gebärende denn soll er das
sagen
dann soll er das sagen so aber
gewährende gebären und das ist keine
Kategorien
gebären nur in einem ganz bestimmten
Augenblick ihres Lebens und ansonsten
sind sie keine Gebärenden gebären sind
im Moment des Gebärens eine Gebärende
Person das ist von US-Präsident Joe
Biden er hat das so eingeführt völliger
falls man Frauen damit meinen sollte es
gibt viele die gebären nie ja und das
Gebärende ist ein aktiver Vorgang der
auch nach dem gebären ganz schnell
abgeschlossen ist gut auch kinderlose
Frauen aber sie wird am Kabinettstisch
gesendet ja da sitzen sie jetzt nicht
aber ihre Partei Kollegen sitzen da mit
den Grünen mit der SPD am Tisch
vielleicht auch meine SMS sie tauschen
sich aus wie läuft es da ab
also ich rede auch von Berlinerinnen und
Berlinern aber dass man nicht richtig
geändert so das könnte man jetzt auch
schon als Gendern beschreiben aber ich
sage nur noch okay immer verstehst so
aber ich sage in der in in der Breite
wie sie ist jetzt hier ausgeführt haben
tue ich es selber mache ich es auch
nicht und
insoweit ich kann ihn wirklich nicht
sagen wie am Kabinettstisch gesprochen
wird ich bin nicht regierungsmittel die
Frage kann ich ihn nicht beantworten die
stellen sie mal jemand in der nächsten
Sendung wenn jemand aus dem
Bundeskabinett ist uns gerade so
eindringlich aus ihrem Leben geschildert
wenn sie jetzt so eine Diskussion hören
muss auch um tiefere Probleme aber eben
auch um diese kleinen Feinheiten der
Sprache geht sagen sie da verliert man
mich jetzt völlig ist mir doch total
egal ob jetzt jemand gendert oder
gebärend oder Mutter oder in oder ein
Sternchen das kann
Lebensrealität drin und die
freundschaftsstelle sind also es wird
mir ja vorgegeben ne also wenn ich jetzt
ein Mann es gibt abgeben würde beim
Verlag wo beendet wird das würden die
gerne Strucken also von daher ist es
natürlich eine Problematik die mich sehr
sehr betrifft an deren und das ist
tatsächlich so ja also da wird schon
sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt und
wir haben ja sowieso haben wir ja
sowieso und das ist ja auch so ein
bisschen ich bekomme oft gesagt wir
haben ja noch die Meinungsfreiheit in
Deutschland du kannst ja deine Meinung
äußern und dann sage ich immer ja aber
Meinungsfreiheit heißt solange ich mich
auf den Boden der Rechtsstaatlichkeit
bewege dass ich meine Meinung äußern
kann und muss keine Konsequenz
befürchten und das ist nicht mehr der
Fall und ich habe das noch nicht wieder
gesehen ich habe auf Facebook hatte ich
eine Erlebnis kurzgeschildert ich war
auf dem Friedhof und habe da das gerade
von meinem Bruder gemacht und wollte
gehen und da war eine Frau und die sagt
hallo Entschuldigung könnten sie noch
ein bisschen bleiben und Sache brauchen
sie Hilfe sagt sie hat so Angst ja sie
ist schon zweimal fast überfallen worden
ja so und
hat mir eben erzählt es waren
offensichtlich Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und sie hat Angst
und ob ich bleiben könnte und ich habe
gesagt guten habe sie dann das
grabfertig machen lassen und hatte
darüber auf Facebook dann einfach nur
geschrieben hat weil mich das so
beschäftigt hat auch das ist von
Facebook gelöscht worden ja es war meine
Erfahrung ne also
wir kommen jetzt zu ihrem Thema wir
kommen jetzt von der großen Politik
quasi zu Berliner Politik denn auch da
sorgen sie sich Sorgen sie sich um
innere Sicherheit es gab viele Themen in
der Hauptstadt aber auch in ganz
Deutschland die innere Sicherheit noch
mehr auf den Plan gerufen haben ihre
Zeit ihre Forderung ja ich finde wir
haben hier in der Hauptstadt durchaus
ein Problem wenn der erste Mai zum
ersten Januar wird wenn wir erleben dass
es keinerlei Respekt mehr für Einsatz
und Sicherheitskräfte und unserer Stadt
gibt und wenn man zu der
Schlussfolgerung kommen muss das gerade
in der Hauptstadt Deutschland durch eine
Linkskoalition das still toleriert wird
wenn wir über einen die Beweislastumkehr
bei der Berliner Polizei sprechen statt
uns hinter die Beamten im Einsatz zu
stellen die jeden Tag unseren
rechtsstaatsverteidigen dann müssen wir
hinschauen wenn wir sehen dass es eine
eine politisch handelnde Partei in
dieser Stadt gibt mit Justiz Senatoren
und Stadträten die clankriminalität
nicht begegnen sondern sich hier noch
schützend davor stellen was meine ich
damit wenn eine bezirksstadträtin in
Neukölln am Ende ein verbundeinsatz der
Polizei unterbindet und verhindert wo
man gemeinsam mit den Ordnungskräften
hätte vorgehen können dann haben wir ein
Problem mit unserem Land und ich glaube
dass wir hier in der Stadt Berlin
deshalb eine stärkere Justiz brauchen
die besser ausgestattet ist mit mehr
Richterinnen und Richtern mit einer
besseren Digitalisierung einer engeren
Zusammenarbeit mit der Innenbehörde und
Brennpunkt Staatsanwaltschaften zu
schaffen und wir gerade in den Regionen
wo wir diese Ereignisse erlebt haben
über ein neues aufstiegsversprechen
reden das heißt deutlich machen dass wir
uns um Bildungs- und die Arbeit kümmern
das bedeutet wenn ihre Partei reinkommt
hier in der Hauptstelle wird es mehr
Richter geben mehr Polizisten geben mehr
Ausstattung geben das haben wir immer in
jeder Haushaltsberatung in den letzten
sechs Jahren hier in Berlin beantragt
und es wurde immer abgelehnt das wurde
immer abgelehnt gerade von Grünen und
Linken die gesagt haben wir haben kein
mehr Bedarf in dieser Stadt bei
Richterinnen und Richtern wir müssen die
Justiz nicht besser ausstatten wir
müssen nicht die Justiz besser
digitalisieren ja das würden wir weil
wir haben eine wachsende Stadt die auch
wachsende Anforderungen hat und in
keiner Stadt in Deutschland erleben wir
mehr Auseinandersetzung als hier wieso
haben wir hier mehr kriminelle Kleber
auf den Straßen als in anderen
Bundesländern
aus meiner Sicht weil man diese Dinge
hier still toleriert und weiß dass es
hier ein politisches Klima gibt wo man
immer ans Äußerste gehen kann und
deshalb sage ich wir haben in dieser
Stadt kein Problem an Gesetzen sondern
wir haben ein Vollzugsdefizit und diese
Selbstverständlichkeiten die möchte ich
in Berlin wieder herstellen damit wir in
dieser Stadt endlich das nicht mehr
erleben und klarere Regeln auch
durchsetzen und die Beamten in dieser
Stadt auch Stärken im Einsatz im Dienst
den sie für uns alle jeden Tag
vollziehen und dieser Stadt denn hinter
jeder Uniform steckt eben auch eine
Mutter oder ein Vater der hier in dieser
Stadt Verantwortung übernimmt für uns
alle ist die erste Verteidigungslinie
unseres recht Staates und die würde ich
gerne wieder stärken und das ist eine
alte Forderung also ich erinnere mich
hat das vor über zehn Jahren schon
gefordert dass die Justiz besser
aufgestellt wird damals auch unter dem
Aspekte wie kriegt man
Jugendkriminalität aus migrantischen
Milieus in den Griff auch natürlich im
Sinne der Jugendlichen nicht nur im
Sinne der Gesellschaft sondern wenn man
die sind auch verloren wenn sie
irgendwann eine eine dauerkriminelle
Karriere haben und aus ihnen nichts mehr
gescheites wird also wie man die
Probleme wirklich angeht das haben wir
schon verschiedentlich auch kluge Leute
gesagt das ist nur nie passiert worden
und da haben sie völlig recht das sind
Vollzugs Problem weil es eben auch in
der in der Politik diejenigen gibt die
sagen alles ist gut in Berlin wir müssen
gar nichts machen ja auch in den Schulen
auch da haben wir natürlich wir haben
Brennpunkt Schulen da brennt die Hütte
sozusagen und ich habe das selber erlebt
in einem Fall in der Köln wo auch eine
Beratungsstelle sich der der Themen
annehmen wollte da hieß es sofort
Rassismus Generalverdacht dann machen
wir gar nichts ja so dabei gibt es ja
viele Schulen mittlerweile die
tatsächlich Sicherheitsdienste
beschäftigt haben ja was so zu unserer
Schulzeit noch völlig und denkbar war
das ist sehr häufig so also ich habe da
auch gerade für die FDP Mann Vortrag
gehalten mit Lehrern und über
schulkriminalität geht das ist auch ein
riesen Thema das sind amerikanische
verhält aber ich finde wir haben ja
jetzt eine ich finde es gut dass wir
diese Diskussion heute hier führen weil
meine Sorge ist dass Silvester und der
erste januar immer blasser wird und wir
uns wieder dieser Diskussionen unserer
Stadt nicht stellen die wesentlich
umfänglicher ist wo wir auch an die
Ursachen ran müssen wo wir auch deutlich
machen müssen das Postleitzahl und
Herkunft nicht über die Chancen eines
Kindes entscheiden dürfen sondern das
Bildungssystem stärker sein muss
deswegen
erneuern und dass wir ein
funktionierenden Rechtsstaat haben und
da sind wir hier in dieser Stadt einfach
auch schlecht aufgestellt und wenn ich
sehe dass
das eben jetzt von der Tagesordnung
einfach wegkommt dann werden wir diese
Ereignisse leider wieder in der Stadt
erleben und das möchte
Berlin von Bayern was lernen
auch das ist die alte Platte Türe also
von Bayern lernen heißt dies und jenes
alles mögliche anführen ich glaube die
Bayern und die Berliner sind immer gut
miteinander ausgekommen zwar immer
früher hat man gesagt Hassliebe
Verhältnisse also ich ist ein besonderes
Verhältnis und ich bin immer stolz
darauf ganz ganz viele Berliner im
Urlaub in meinem Wahlkreis zu haben
zwischen Chiemsee und Königsee und das
Wasser Werbeteil
ich war ein großer Verfechter im Jahr
1991 in Bonn zu verbleiben das war einer
meiner wenigen politischen Fehler muss
ich sagen ich bin froh dass das alles
nach Berlin gegangen ist und ich fühle
mich hier wohl unter der Voraussetzung
dass ich immer naja wenn man in der
Berliner in der politischen Blase ist
ist es etwas anders als die Bilder die
jetzt auch eingeblendet waren in
Neukölln und so weit ist das sind zwei
Welten eigentlich mit dem unser eins
kommt mit dem wenigen Verbindung ich bin
Silvester Neujahr einfach nicht in
Berlin und da bin ich im Rügen Bayern
in Berlin
schöne Aussage wissen sie dass das würde
ich mir von viel mehr Politikern noch
wünschen na dass sie gesagt haben dass
sie da weniger Berührungspunkte haben
weil genauso ist es auch anders
ich dachte hier wird von einem anderen
Berlin berichtet aber das ist natürlich
das wahre Berlin und unser Rechtsstaat
steht doch unter Dauerfeuer an diesen
Stellen schauen Sie doch total Feuer ja
was was hier am ersten Mai am ersten
Januar passiert ist schauen Sie nach
lützrad wir können ja uns mit all diesen
Fragen auseinandersetzen und deshalb
finde ich es wichtig dass man in diesen
Zeiten eben auch deutlich sagt wenn der
Rechtsstaat so unter Dauerfeuer steht da
müssen wir auch dafür sorgen dass der
Rechtsstaat besser funktioniert oder
hier in Berlin die
Selbstverständlichkeiten funktionieren
und ich finde es dann hoch irritierend
wenn die Grünen in Nordrhein-Westfalen
darüber nachdenken das Thema Clan
Kriminalität aus dem polizeilichen
Lagebild zu streichen weil sie der
Auffassung sind dass das da ähm
hineingehört
so dann greifen dann müssen wir das
Finden
Klartext über diese Frage sprechen und
und uns besser aufstellen so Ende
Wahlkampf
vielen herzlichen Dank Ende der Sendung
Ende der Sendung mit vielen Dank an
meine Gäste das war viertel nach acht
wir sehen uns morgen wieder dann ist
übrigens von den Linken kantina Schubert
hier das ist wahrscheinlich für Sie auch
eine interessante freue mich wenn wir
uns morgen Wiedersehen bis dann
[Musik]